كل من يتعامل في الاسواق المصريه دون ان
يكون مسجلا لدى الحكومه او يدفع ضرائب
يكون منتميا للاقتصاد غير الرسمي الامر
ينسحب على الباعه الجاهلين او على العمال
الذين يعملون كافراد بالاجر اليوميه وفي
بعض الاحيان ينضم اليهم من يقومون ببعض
اعمال الزراعه او التصنيع البسيط او حتى
سائق التوك توك هذه المركبه التي بدات
الحكومه المصريه مؤخرا في اصدار تراخيص
لها في بعض المحافظات حتى تخرج من الظل
الى النور احمد احد السائقين الذين لم
يرخصوا مركبتهم بعد على الوظيفه
التعبان كنت ما طلعتش اصلا مش مترخص وكده
برده ما اقدرش اطلع بيه بره وكده اشتغل بس
في قلب منطقه بس في تكاتك بس في الجيزه
بترخص بس هي هنا في القاهره
الترخيص عالي قوي دلوقتي اصلا فاهمني على
صفحات التواصل الاجتماعيه هناك الاف ممن
يبيعون منتجات عن طريق توصيلها للمنازل
وهددت الدوله بملاحقتهم كما طلبت من صانع
المحتوى كذلك تسجيل انفسهم لدى السلطات
المصريه لدفع الضرائب الدكتوره داليا
بركات تشرح سبب تفضيل الملايين للعمل
بعيدا عن الاضواء اول حاجه بيفكر فيها
فكره الضرائب مفهوم النظام الضريبي ده
بالنسبه له بعبع انا ايش عرفني هيفردوا
علي غريبه عامله ازاي ممكن ضرائب بيكون
بتتقدر بشكل جذافي اكثر من اللي انا الدخل
اللي بيدخل لي همم الخوف من البيروقراطيه
والاجراءات التكلفه او العيب ان انا برده
همم عشان اروح لها واعمل الاجراءات دي
دراسه اصدرها مركز تابع لرئاسه الوزراء
قدرت ان 60% من حجم الاقتصاد المصريه دوره
بالتوازي في مسار غير الرسميه فلا يسدد
ضرائب ولكن في نفس الوقت يوفر فرص عمل
للملايين فما السبي اقناع هؤلاء بامساك
الدفاتر
ندي له حوافز نشوف الدول المتقدمه زي
الصين سنغافوره عملوا ايه هناك هنشجعكم
على التصدير هنصدر لكم منتجاتكم وهنروج
اكثر لمنتجاتكم فانا لما احس ان انا داخلي
هيزيد بشكل كبير فاكيد بالنسبه لي اللي
انا طبعا اساهم واللي انا ادخل وانضم
الاقتصاد الرسمي
يحرموا الموازنه من حصيله ضريبيه تقدر
بنحو 400 مليار جنيه والتي يمكن ان تغطي
ما يقرب من 85% من اجمالي العكس تامر
العربيه القاهره